Good morning, John! I --
just looked at my calendar, and I realized that there's no freaking way
that I could possibly make a video next week because I'm going to be
all over Los Angeles. I am setting up my tripod.
So I just asked Twitter what I should do and I got an amazing suggestion
I'm a pro! Zoot! I'm gonna zoom in and I'm gonna clean up some of those laundrys real quick
And when I say clean up, I mean move from here to a little bit off frame
You'll maybe be surprised to know that Dave the fish is still here, just not in great shape
So here's the idea, I turned on my mic so now I sound better,
It's from Morgan who says "Review Broadway shows just based off their descriptions on Wikipedia"
This is a great idea! This person should choose all of my video topics.
Hello, Wikipedia Category Broadway musicals. Ah, there's a loooot of them!
I'm just gonna click a bunch and see what happened.
And where's, where the website go?
American Dance Machine, which I assume is a musical about a robot made in America that dances,
now there is a bunch of other dancers in the musical but just one robot
This musical has a lot, lot of choreographers. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10 choreographers!
I mean, at this point, are they choreographers or are they robot programmers?
Clicky, clicky, clicky.
Banjo Eyes. Although Canter was known as banjo eyes, the title referred not to his character
but to a talking racehorse played in costume by the Vaudeville team of Morton and Mayo
Okay!
It has songs like: Birthday Card, and Valentine's day Card.
There is also a number called Mother's Day, but not Mother's Day Card
because this was before Mother's Day cards.
Oh! This is, ah, this this giant lists I have been looking at is just A, B, C, and D!
There's so many Broadway plays!
Clicky, clicky, clicky, click.
It's a Bird.. It's a Plane... It's Superman! There's a Superman musical from 1966!
Why didn't anybody tell me about this!?
They did a TV special in 1975?
Is that on You... Is that on YouTube? It sure better be.
Come on...
Oh it is! Oh it is! The whole thing!
This is less good than every YouTube video.
Oh my God, it's beautiful!
They should have sent a poet.
Clicky, clicky, clicky, opening my eyes!
Nothing happened.
The Cocoanuts Musical
The Cocoanut, is this, is that how you spell coconuts and I am just crazy?
*Breathy gibberish*
Wait.
The more famous film adaptation was released in 1929
Let's see if that one's available.
Just just the preview for it
That's
The Cocoanuts
Clicky, clicky, clicky, clicky
I never know how...
Okay, we got one.
Marriage a la Carte.
That sounds like a bad idea.
We've got songs like: Thrifty Little Marel, Silly Cock-a-Doodle-Doo, and uh, Of All Her Sex A Paragon.
Lets listen to Of All Her Sex a Paragon
Marriage a la Carte, Library of Congress
related items of All Her Sex a Paragon.
Sorry we can't find what you're looking for.
It's been erased!
It's a black file.
I just made up the term black file, but I think it's really good
Maybe I didn't, what's a black file?
(Hank searches): Black File
It's a nail salon.
Are any of the songs?
Captain Dinklepop!
How is there a song called Captain Dinklepop and I can't listen to it?
Catch up internet!
Get on my level!
Marriage al a Carte gets 10 out of 10 Dinklepops!
Click, click, click.
Teddy & Alice.
This is from 1987.
Fictionalized account of the relationship between Teddy Roosevelt and his daughter Alice, huh.
Teddy & Alice suggested Roosevelt's problems with his daughter stemmed from an obsession with his late wife
Frank Rich of the New York Times compared it to a halftime show at a high school football game
Let's give that one, just like a zero teddy bears.
Hey Morgan, thanks for the idea.
Hey, everyone in the world. You can spell coconuts with an a if you want.
John congrats on Turtles All the Way Down,
I'm really proud of you. I'm very excited for it.
And I will see you.... What am, who am I kidding we'll probably be hanging out right now, it's VidCon.
Bye!